THE EXPERT OF EXPERTS ON CHINA
EXPOSES THAT ALL.
BUT THIS IS AMERICA IN SHUTDOWN,
DAY 22.
IT WAS JUST A FEW WEEKS AGO THAT
WE WERE HEARING VERY SCARY
NUMBERS LIKE THESE.
SPEAK OF THE NUMBER WAS
2.2 MILLION PEOPLE HAVE DIED.
2.2 MILLION PEOPLE WOULD HAVE
DIED IN A SHORT PERIOD OF TIME.
>> AS YOU SAW ON THAT SLIDE,
THAT WAS A REAL NUMBER, THAT
100000-200,000.
AND WE THINK THAT THAT IS THE
RANGE.
>> AMERICANS BE PREPARED FOR THE
LIKELIHOOD THAT THERE WILL BE
100,000 AMERICANS WHO DIE FROM
THIS VIRUS.
>> THE ANSWER IS YES.
AS SOBERING A NUMBER AS THAT IS,
WE SHOULD BE PREPARED FOR IT.
>> Laura: BUT NOW IT LOOKS
LIKE THOSE PROJECTIONS, WHICH
DROVE THE EXPERTS TO RECOMMEND
AN AGGRESSIVE ECONOMIC SHUTDOWN
OF AMERICA, WERE WILDLY OFF BASE
BASE.
>> THE HEAD OF THE CENTERS FOR
DISEASE CONTROL NOW SAYS U.S.
CORONAVIRUS DEBTS COULD BE MUCH
LOWER THAN THE HUNDRED THOUSAND
OR 240,000 PREDICTED BY SOME
EARLIER MODEL.
>> EVERY MODEL IS ONLY AS GOOD
AS THE ASSUMPTIONS THAT GO INTO
IT.
ORIGINALLY THE ASSUMPTION WAS
THAT FEWER AMERICANS WOULD KEEP
THEIR DISTANCE.
>> Laura: BUT YOU WELL
BEHAVED, SO THINGS ARE BETTER.
I UNDERSTAND WHAT WE ARE TALKING
ABOUT HERE.
THE FINAL DEATH COUNT TODAY IS
PROJECTED TO BE ABOUT 80,000
PEOPLE.
IN OTHER WORDS, 30 TIMES FEWER
THAN THE HIGH-END OF WHAT WAS
ORIGINALLY FORECAST, THAT
2.2 MILLION FIGURE, AND THREE
TIMES FEWER THAN THE 240,000
NUMBER.
WE KNOW THERE -- THAT OUR
COUNTRY IS STILL EXPERIENCING
EXCRUCIATING LOSS, THE LOSS OF
LIFE, AND WE BELIEVE, AS WE SET
EVERY NIGHT BUT EVERY LIFE IS
PRECIOUS, EVERY DEATH MATTERS
DUE TO WHATEVER CAUSE.
IT’S WORTH ASKING WHAT WHAT OUR
RESPONSE EVENT AND WHAT ARE
RESPONSIVE UNLESS DAMAGING TO
THE ECONOMY, TO THE LIVES OF ALL
OF YOU MILLIONS OF AMERICANS, IF
WE HAD HAD MORE ACCURATE MODELS
FROM THE START?
AND SHOULDN’T THIS EXPERIENCE
MAKE US LESS WILLING TO RELY ON
THE SAME EXPERTS TO HELP
DETERMINE WHEN AND HOW WE SHOULD
REOPEN OUR ECONOMY?
MEANWHILE, IN EUROPE, THE
LEADERS OF NORWAY, DENMARK,
CZECH REPUBLIC AND AUSTRIA HAVE
ANNOUNCED PLANS TO RELAX
CORONAVIRUS LOCKDOWN
RESTRICTIONS.
NORWAY WILL END ITS BAN ON
FAMILY TRAVELING TO THEIR
HOLIDAY COTTAGES ON APRIL 20TH.
OTHER BUSINESSES WILL BE ALLOWED
TO REOPEN THEN TOO.
DENMARK?
WELL, THEY WILL PRESS AHEAD WITH
A CAUTIOUS REOPENING OF DAY CARE
AND PRIMARY SCHOOLS ARTICLE 15.
TALKS ARE UNDERWAY TO GET THE
BUSINESSES UP AND RUNNING AGAIN
AS WELL.
AND MORE GOOD NEWS FROM GERMANY,
WHICH IS THE THIRD-LARGEST
OUTBREAK IN EUROPE.
THEY SAW THE NUMBER OF DAILY
RECOVERIES OUTNUMBER NEW COVID
CASES FOR THE FIRST TIME ON
TUESDAY.
CHECK OUT THEIR NEW INFECTIONS
CURVE.
LOOKING MUCH BETTER.
BUT IN FRANCE, THE GOVERNMENT
THERE HAS DECIDED TO TAKE AWAY
THE ONE THING PEOPLE HAD LEFT TO
KEEP THEM, FRANKLY, SANE, BY
DECIDING TO BAN OUTDOOR DAYTIME
EXERCISE.
THAT SEEMS TOTALLY NUTS TO ME.
I’M NOT AN EXPERT IN THESE
THINGS BUT EXERCISE HAS SO MANY
HEALTH BENEFITS THAT WOULD SEEM
TO OUTWEIGH THE RISKS THAT
YOU’RE GOING TO GET CORONAVIRUS
WHEN YOU RUN OR BIKE PAST
SOMEONE ON A TRAIL.
ALTHOUGH -- I DON’T KNOW,
PHYSICAL EXERTION, EVEN INDOORS,
CAN POSE ITS OWN CHALLENGES.
>> LETTING GO!
♪ ♪
>> Laura: AND FINALLY, YOU
FEEL IT, DON’T YOU?
THAT AMERICA IS GETTING
INCREASINGLY ANXIOUS ABOUT THE
SHUTDOWN.
AND GIVEN THE FACT THAT THE
DEATH RATE FOR COVID-19 MAY END
UP BEING ONLY SLIGHTLY WORSE
THAN A VERY TOUGH FLU SEASON, WE
WANT ANSWERS.
WE WANT OBJECTIVE METRICS FOR
RESTARTING THINGS.
>> THIS IDEA OF REOPENING UP THE
ECONOMY.
THERE’S A SWITCH THAT YOU CAN
JUST TURN IT BACK ON -- HOW DOES
THE ADMINISTRATION ENVISION THIS
HAPPENING?
>> A FIRST MISSION IS TO SAVE
LIVES, BUT THERE IS A DUAL TRACK
THAT THE PRESIDENT HAS ALREADY
INITIATED.
SOME OF THE BEST MINDS HERE AT
THE WHITE HOUSE ARE BEGINNING TO
THINK ABOUT WHAT RECOMMENDATIONS
WOULD LOOK LIKE THAT WE GIVE TO
BUSINESSES, THAT WE GIVE TO
STATES.
>> Laura: WELL, A LITTLE
VAGUE, BUT WHAT ABOUT PARENTS
AND THEIR CHILDREN?
ARE THEY EVER GOING TO GO BACK
TO SCHOOL?
>> WHAT YOU THINK SUMMER CAMP
HOLDS AND WHAT YOU THINK THE
START OF NEXT SCHOOL YEAR HOLDS?
>> IT IS UNPRINTABLE, BUT YOU
CAN GET A FEEL FOR IF WE START
TALKING ABOUT THE THINGS WHERE
THE CURVE GOES DOWN AND WE
REALLY HAVE MINIMUM -- HOW WE
RESPOND AND WHAT KIND OF A
REBOUND WE SEE OR DON’T SEE.
>> Laura: YOU KNOW WHAT ELSE
IS GOING LIKE THIS?
RETENTION OF INFORMATION.
KIDS LEARNING.
THAT’S WHAT A LOT OF PARENTS ARE
EMAILING ME AND THANK YOU, KEEP
THE EMAIL COMING, BUT THOSE
ANSWERS ARE MURKY, RIGHT?
THEY DON’T GIVE YOUR SENSE OF
WHAT ARE WE LOOKING AT HERE?
REMEMBER, AS MUCH AS WE RESPECT
AND ADMIRE ALL THOSE WHO ARE ON
THE FRONT LINES OF OUR
HEALTH CARE SYSTEM, ESPECIALLY
DOCTORS, NURSES, ALL THE STAFF,
WE DIDN’T VOTE FOR DOCTORS.
WE DIDN’T VOTE FOR MODELERS OR
STATISTICIANS, AS BRILLIANT AS
MANY OF THEM CAN BE.
WE VOTED FOR POLITICAL
LEADERSHIP THAT SEES THE BIG
PICTURE.
THAT MEANS THE WHOLE PICTURE OF
AMERICA.
BECAUSE WE ALL KNOW -- WE WALK
OUT THE FRONT DOOR, LIFE ENTAILS
RISKS.
THE VULNERABLE NEED PROTECTION,
ESPECIALLY THE ELDERLY AND THOSE
WITH UNDERLYING CONDITIONS.
AND IT IS THE SAME TIME, FREEDOM
MEETS PRESERVING.
WE JUST CANNOT HAVE OUR PEOPLE
DENIED THE ABILITY TO MAKE A
LIVING, GO TO SCHOOL, ATTEND
WORSHIP SERVICES, TRAVEL AS THEY
WISH, SEE THEIR FRIENDS.
WE NEED A REALISTIC METRICS.
WE NEED CLEAR PROTOCOL TO GIVE
PEOPLE PEACE OF MIND ONCE WE DO
RESTART OUR ECONOMY AND REOPEN
AGAIN.
WE WANT PEOPLE TO GO BACK TO
RESTAURANTS AND SO FORTH.
WE WANT THOSE BUSINESSES TO NOT
JUST SURVIVE, BUT THRIVE AGAIN.
OTHERWISE WE RISK CREATING A NEW
EPIDEMIC, ONE OF CONTINUING MASS
UNEMPLOYMENT, DEPRESSION,
SOCIETAL FALLOUTS, EVEN THE
MEDICAL EXPERTS TODAY STILL
CAN’T FORESEE.